Matt how you doing buddy hey what's up
Ryan good morning good morning um
the Cowboys we've been talking about
early on here you watched a play out
yesterday what's happened to him three
and Oh to start Super Bowl contenders
everybody thought and now they lose
three in a row into the Jets yesterday
where are they at right now where
they're going yeah it's the talk right
now I mean I think they played some
pretty bad teams early on and they came
out like gangbusters I think that week
one we weren't really sure what kind of
offense they're gonna have dak Prescott
was the top story in the news because of
his contract situation Zeke and the
holdout and all that stuff and they came
out amazing I think they were averaging
like 32 points a game then it's been the
slow slow steady decline and I think
there's a lot of blame to go around but
losing to the Jets you know sometimes
you can overlook a team and I think the
week before I don't know that I've seen
a team look as bad as the Jets looked on
film and so I think you know the Cowboys
are human they probably thought they
were gonna come in there and all over
them and they found themselves in a
dogfight and they didn't have answers
for the Blitz and their defense is
continuing to play poorly they're bad
and field position the defense isn't
getting any takeaways and you know their
offense to hoopla come up with a play in
the red zone when they needed it most
so the NFC is a crapshoot right San
Francisco clearly has become a team but
are the Saints with Teddy Bridgewater
knowing that Drew Brees may come back
are they do you think the team to beat
in the NFC well you know I'd pick the
Saints to go to the Super Bowl and win
the Super Bowl this year and you know I
did that not knowing that Drew Brees
would get hurt you know so when he got
hurt I wasn't feeling great about my
pick I was feeling like oh shoot man I
that's so bad luck kind of like when you
draft somebody on your fantasy team and
you're hoping for this great year and
you're the guy's a great player and all
of a sudden like he's out like dang
there goes the whole season there goes
the year but the Saints did something
that is not a lot of teams do they've
invested in the quarterback position you
know a lot of people talk about how
Shaun Pete is in love with
Amil he tells everybody better listen
he's the next Steve Young or on to
something well if he's the next Steve
Young why is teddy bridgewater one of
the highest-paid
backups in the league like well they've
over invested in the quarterback
position and you know this is a team
that has Drew Brees the first ballot
hall-of-famer on their roster so the
fact that they did is huge for them
right now it's a reason that they're 5
into 1 it's a reason that they're
undefeated at home undefeated in their
division and people are saying this is
the team to beat and you know like you
mentioned I think the 49ers will have
something to say about that I think the
Seahawks will have something to say
about that and even in their own
division I think the Carolina Panthers
have quietly you know won four in a row
with their backup quarterback who from
what I have heard a lot of people feel
like Kyle Allen gives them a better
chance to win then a not a hundred
percent Cam Newton so I think is NFC
race is still pretty good and you know
by the way there's a guy named Aaron
Rodgers if it's going to have something
to say about it
well yeah he goes at it tonight against
the Detroit Lions and Matthew Stafford
talking about those Saints team do they
have a really good chance though to go
undefeated in to their bye week with
Teddy Bridgewater at quarterback I mean
Arizona and I think Chicago are there at
Chicago and then Arizona in the next two
weeks before the bye I mean that's if if
they look at that and they walk away
with an undefeated record with Teddy
Bridgewater the starting quarterback
sky's the limit for this football team
yeah I agree but I really think they
can't fall for that trap like they gotta
look at it as one game at a time you
know they're they're five in one but
they very easily could have lost a bunch
of these game you know I was at that at
Monday Night Football game against
Houston you know that make it a lost
that game a hundred different ways and
you know they were really fortunate that
their special teams are so good and you
know they were able to kick a
game-winner I believe at the end you
know I think they just got it they can't
fall for the trap of looking ahead and
I'll say this the guy that really makes
it all go for me is Alvin Kamara he's
the most underrated guys in the league
and to call him underrated is probably
kind of wild because I think I think
most people know how good he is but when
he's not out on the field they are a
different team I go back to the game
last year against Dallas this is kind of
when people started getting hot on
Dallas all of a sudden it was a Thursday
night game Alvin Kamara gets knocked out
of the game and that's when they had
Mark Ingram and it was just a completely
different look it was a completely
different team and I think latavius
Murray is a good player I think there's
some good players out there but without
Alvin camara I just don't think there is
explosive and as dangerous as they are
with them with him they're definitely a
super Super Bowl contender no doubt
about it without him I don't know if
they're the same you talk to us about
Kyle Allen a little bit and how he's
performed in the absence of Cam Newton
is that one of the examples you talk
about when Cam Newton comes back healthy
has Kyle Allen pulled a Tom Brady Drew
Bledsoe scenario here is he gonna be the
guy when cam new one comes back healthy
I mean I do think you like if you just
look at the numbers okay so cam starts
the year he's owned two had no
touchdowns he's got a pick he's
completing about half of his passes and
then kind of Allen comes in in rug run
sort of Turner's offense the way that
it's supposed to be run not muscle and
through it or anything like that just on
time accurate passes in the system and
he's four no he's got seven touchdown
passes no interceptions 66 complete
completion percent completion percentage
I mean that those are just the numbers
but then there is an intangible factor
that I think Cam Newton brings and he's
always brought you know it's like wow
he's such a weapon as a runner hard to
defend in the red zone but the other
intangible didn't he measure it what's
that lock on one like walk home who does
that locker room really want to be
teammates with lock-step West
I've never been teammate to cam but he
just strikes me as an odd individual and
maybe he's teaming like connect with him
in a way
I don't understand and that's fun and
don't say all the right things publicly
but like you know Ryan like you're in a
locker room with a guy it's like yeah
the kind of guy I know I can't count on
I know that his priority his first
priority is us winning all the time and
that he can do whatever he can do and
like maybe that's Kim and maybe that's
cam in that locker room but there's
there's a cool that it's not and so when
you get a guy playing the way that Kyle
Allen's been playing and you need a
minimum salary guy basically free to the
team on a rookie deal and then you got a
guy that's making like 19 million
dollars a year and you're in there you
tube channel and all this other stuff
like there's an out there there's
probably a situation where it might
split the team or the team might look at
it as an opportunity and now I'm not
trying to take a shot at cam at all the
same similar thing happened with Tony
Romo and dak Prescott
once upon a time Tony Romo was making
about 16 million a year that Prescott
was on a rookie deal he's cheaper the
team's like hey you know we like you
both but we can ride with this guy like
this guy work and so like you know who
knows I'm just I guess from my
perspective sitting back and watching it
not being in that locker room it would
not surprise me at all if if by the end
of the year they had a different
quarterback if the quota if the other
guy had the hot hand it wouldn't
surprise we're talking to Matt
Hasselbeck ESPN on the NFL you played
quarterback for all those years and you
were a starter and you were a backup and
it never any at any point did I look at
you and think you know diva or just just
so much so much outside the realm of
playing the quarterback position and to
your point we just see Cam Newton show
up in the outfits we see him show up on
YouTube with the cigar and his wine and
I mean all the things that go into it
plays into effect what you just said
Kyle Allen shows up in his Subaru
hatchback and you know jumps out and
goes for a know how the rest of that
team isn't just vibing off that when it
comes to the opportunity for a campaign
I just I think it's a no-brainer yeah
well in in that's a question really for
the guys in the locker room more than it
is for me but I I know this whatever
they say publicly that is not true like
it's like you say when publicly what
you're supposed to say publicly I think
not true it's not necessarily true and I
think that's true for every team in the
in the NFL like you say what you're
supposed to say about your teammates
about your coach about the opponent hey
what do you guys what do you think about
this team right here are there well
coach team they're real you know a
really good opponent but you watch the
film like you know the truth or even
like the guys that are on a team it's
like hey do you think that the head
coach should be fired no no absolutely
not he's great he's the best but that's
not necessarily how you really feel so
there is a there is a real answer there
I don't know what it is but just from a
distance I think the door is open for a
team that's won four in a row and
they've got high aspirations they're
trying to chase those New Orleans Saints
and teams around the league even playing
well backup quarterbacks speaking of the
quarterback position we saw a matchup
between deshaun Watson and Patrick
mahomes this weekend and you know it's a
bit of an overreaction Monday but could
we start to say the reigning MVP and
Mitchell true Biscay playing into the
playoffs a year ago with that Chicago
team could we be starting to see the
Shaun Watson is possibly the best
quarterback drafted in that to sau 2017
draft well I mean I look I love deshaun
Watson I'm not ready to say that you
know I actually picked the Saints and
the Texans as my Super Bowl teams I mean
I feel strongly about this John Watson
but I still think Pratt's columns is in
a in a category of his own with that
being said it's really important doing
right now Bill O'Brien is quietly you're
after here up here done a nice job in
Houston
deshaun Watson I did a piece kind of a
little segment on him on Sunday and if
I'll count down this week you know
basically how people attacked him last
year they basically said hey listen we
can confuse him at the line of scrimmage
we can get him to try to process a ton
of information in a show
amount of time can cause him to hold the
ball we can get sacks and get them
behind the chains this year he has
showed up he has done the work he knows
exactly where to go with the ball he's
recognizing fronts he's recognizing
blitzes from life Becker's safeties from
DBS and he's making you pay I go back to
that Monday Night Football game Saints
versus Texans and they brought the house
like they brought free safety pressure
in a prevent defense situation they
don't pay I mean he put his team on his
back and said alright let's go win this
thing and they didn't end up getting the
win but it wasn't cause of deshaun
Watson so like I think the Shawn Watson
Patrick mahomes that's like this matchup
that we're going to see for the next
eight to ten years this like Brady vs.
Manning those two teams Houston Kansas
City I think they've got Bright Futures
and you know Houston very well may have
the better team this year and and I
think there's a lot of people that are
picking the Chiefs but Houston has been
incredibly incredibly impressive yeah
and pretty much doing it without DeAndre
Hopkins I think that's been even more
impressive with what he's doing I want
to get you out of here on this one Matt
Hasselbeck from ESPN Baker Mayfield the
hype everything going in not only the
height but his vocal assertions and the
way he's the bravado that he's shown I
always thought that Cleveland needed
somebody like that but when things
started to maybe turn and not live up to
expectations it's gonna it was gonna be
some blow back and we're kind of
starting to see that yesterday you know
putting some blame on the officials not
necessarily taking a solid look in the
mirror what what have you seen from
Baker so far and what do you expect
coming out of the bye week in a couple
weeks yeah yeah well you know I said
this at the beginning of the year with
expectations for Cleveland you know
Baker Mayfield was going to be
challenged this year in a way that he's
probably never been challenged before
and it wasn't going to be with a
football on his hands you know so much
of being a franchise quarterback and
being sort of a leader in that huddle is
what you do
the ball not in your hands and I've
actually been very impressed with them
on how he's handled the media and shut
things down when it was time to shut him
down
he's deflected when it was time to
deflect but they have to find a way to
play better football that's really the
bottom line and I I think that that
coaching staff needs to probably just
come together and figure out what that
identity of the team is going to be I
think that they've got a little bit too
distracted by the weapons that they have
outside it's a wide receiver group and
they've kind of forgot it kind of it
feels like a team that doesn't have a
solid foundation it feels like a team
that is built up on kind of like a
fantasy football mindset more so than a
blue-collar work ethic just like we're
gonna want to start everything with the
run game we're going to look at
everything through the lens of the
offensive line we're going to protect
our quarterback early in the games like
I haven't seen that high completion
percentage style of offense that we saw
last year when they were just like
treating Baker like he was a young
quarterback I think he's going to be a
good quarterback but we can't forget
that he's still a young quarterback
maturing and so what's missing for him I
think that coaching staff has to get on
the same page and I'm not in those
meetings necessarily obviously but but
whatever it is like they have to find a
way to just help him get comfortable in
games instead of holding on the ball too
long and forcing throws and then being
inaccurate on other throws like there's
there's something where you just got to
treat it more like a like Mike Holmgren
used to always say this with all my
quarterbacks you have to walk before you
can run and I think that they just came
out like gangbusters thinking like oh
we're the favourites to the win the
division here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna go for it and and I really
think that that mindset of like walk
before you run would have served this
team better and they probably would be
three and three right now instead of two
and four and it wouldn't feel like the
sky is falling but I'll just end with
this Ryan I don't think it's over for
the Cleveland Browns I actually think
the bake is still
get it together I like their schedule at
the end and they're not out of it well
that's that's making everybody in
Cleveland pretty happy to hear that
coming from you Matt Hasselbeck from
ESPN a buddy thanks for thanks for doing
this my my guest host and a have a great
call this week
Stanford UCLA I'll be listening on
Thursday night good stuff man thank you
Matt Hasselbeck everybody from ESPN for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app